in düsseldorf ist die masken pflicht
jetzt rechtswidrig wir haben den mann
getroffen dafür gesorgt hat er hat dafür
gesorgt dass in düsseldorf keine masken
mehr getragen werden muss die masken
pflicht seien laut antrag von johannes
engel hat rechtswidrig so hat auch das
verwaltungsgericht düsseldorf am montag
entschieden mit der begründung es sei
nicht eindeutig erkennbar wo und waren
die masken pflicht gilt am dienstag soll
das von der stadt eine neue
allgemeinverfügung geben
wegen der offenkundigen rechtswidrigkeit
dieser verfügung der stadt isselburg
es gibt viele punkte die in dieser
verordnung unklar sind und wegen dieser
vielen punkte ist auch die
rechtswidrigkeit festgestellt worden
also ich bin froh dass die masken
pflicht gekippt worden ist weil ich
finde es ehrlich gesagt lächerlich wenn
ich irgendwo auf der straße alleine und
10 20 meter weiter kommt mir eine
entgegen und ich muss da mit einer maske
rumrennen doch mit dieser entscheidung
sind nicht alle bürger einverstanden
einige fürchten einen massiven ausbruch
der chor ohne krankheit bei patienten
mit vorerkrankungen krebskrank was
welche verantwortung haben sich diese
leute gehen die meinungen zur masken
pflicht sind gespalten aber ob sie bei
der neuen allgemeinverfügung am dienstag
enthalten sein wird ist unklar
und jetzt sprechen wir mit johannes
engel hat der mann der dafür gesorgt hat
herr engelhardt wir haben gerade im film
gesehen dass sie sogar auch beschimpft
wurden wie gehen sie denn damit um
zunächst muss ich sagen dass ich mich
sehr freue dass diese masken pflichten
des lochs gekippt es toll dass das
verwaltungsgericht festgestellt hat dass
diese verfügung der stadt düsseldorf
rechtswidrig war in vielen punkten und
über diese entscheidung freue ich mich
sehr
was nicht erfreulich ist dass wir als
gesellschaft uns zunehmend gegeneinander
bewegen
nicht erfreulich ist auch dass ich kurz
vor der sendung gerade einen anruf
bekommen habe anonymen anrufen wenn ich
sie kriegen dieser stadt sehe dann
schlage ich die toten anonym bekommen
und das zeigt ein stück
der wirkung von diesen verfügungen und
auch wie die medien mit dieser krankheit
umgehen
in unserer bevölkerung dass die menschen
wirklich an einer angst neurose leiten
in eine psychose eingetrieben werden
dass jeder seinen nachbarn jetzt als
potenziellen infiziere identifiziert
dass man vorher angst hat dass man sich
voreinander versteckt und das ist
eigentlich der große schaden im moment
in unserer gesellschaft passiert und
dagegen müssen eigentlich alle aufstehen
herr engel hat sie haben uns gerade
erzählt sie haben eine morddrohung
gekommen und wirken auf mich sehr
gefasst wird was macht das mit ihnen wie
geht es ihnen jetzt mir geht's gut
ich freue mich an meiner familie meinen
kindern
ich freue mich auch darüber dass andere
leute angerufen haben und sich bedankt
haben für diesen schritt
ich habe viele zustimmende mitteilungen
bekommen genauso wie dieser anruf habe
mich andere anrufe erreicht auch leute
die gesagt haben dass sie dreistellige
vierstellige beträge geben damit also
endlich diese überzeugung eine
verordnung aus der welt geschafft werden
das ist sehr erfreulich warum finden sie
denn die massen pflicht überzogen also
warum tragen sie nicht die maske
zunächst mal muss man einfach
feststellen dass sämtliche grundlagen
für diese verordnungen auch für das
infektionsschutzgesetz insgesamt nicht
wissenschaftlich begründet sind weder
ist nachgewiesen dass eine maske
überhaupt im zuge dieser corona epidemie
oder dieser dieser krankheit irgend eine
positive auswirkung hätte nachgewiesen
ist inzwischen das dauerndes masken
tragen gesundheitsschädlich ist
insbesondere für kinder und diese sachen
müssten evidenzbasiert geschehen damit
überhaupt eine klare gesetzliche
regelungen erfolgen kann und diese
evidenz also dieser wissenschaftlichen
nachweis ist bis heute überhaupt nicht
gemacht worden
auch diese instanz ziehen aufgrund eines
pcr tests der also keine infektionen
nachweis sondern nur positive
testergebnisse alle diese dinge sind
fehlt die wissenschaftliche grundlage
und von daher sind die verordnungen alle
angreifbar
und die stadt düsseldorf hat ihre
verordnung zurückgezogen und will jetzt
nachlegen was machen sie denn wenn eine
neue verordnung klar regelt wann und wo
man jetzt maske wieder trägt ja sowas so
ich mache das was man als bürger land
holt man liest sich das genau durch und
dann guckt man auch dass dem geltenden
recht entspricht
und auch meinem rechtsempfinden und dann
werde ich mir zusammen mit dem
rechtsanwalt überlegen wie wir damit
umgehen wollte mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dir das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren